zurück bei bild live an kriegstag 18
einem besonders blutigen tag 35 tote
soll es alleine bei dem raketenangriff
auf eine militärbasis nahe lemberg
gegeben haben über diesen angriff
berichten wir ihnen seit heute früh 35
tote und
137 verletzte dazu gleich mehr von
unseren reportern dort und jetzt gerade
erreichen uns diese dramatischen bilder
aus der nähe von kiew aus dieser stadt
in der name ist er möglicherweise in den
letzten tagen schon zu ohren gekommen
dass ist dieser vor ort von kiew in dem
der in dem der beschuss so heftig ist
und von dort schickte uns unser bild
reporter paul ronzheimer gerade diese
bilder von einem angeschossenen
us-journalisten dort in
dramatische aufnahmen der journalist der
sich dort auf dieser trage befindet wird
in den krankenwagen verladen unter den
augen der kollegen und eben auch unter
den kollegen von paul der mir jetzt
verbunden ist
dort in der nähe von kiew paul das sind
dramatisch sehen von deinem kollegen
beschreiben uns einmal was dort gerade
passiert ist
ja kein wie man dort haben der brücke
die in den vergangenen tagen ja bereits
immer wieder gezeigt wurde wo anwohner
versuchen aus ihrem team über diese
brücke in diese richtung zu kommt man
den checkpoint wir sind sozusagen in
einer frage was
was sozusagen
damit hat dass dieser anwohner dort
brauchen evakuiert werden konnten und am
ende ist
es eine szene gewesen dass der
journalist vor dieser brücke offenbar
angeschossen worden ist
möglicherweise sind weitere kollegen
aufgekommen dass beim nächsten gäste
zeitpunkt noch nicht sagen was wir sagen
können ist dass der beschuss heftig war
heute in das ist ja von allen seiten so
zu sagen
wir können einer ganz kurz horchen ihr
beziehungsweise eure kollegen habt
sprechen können mit dem wer ist
journalistin der dort angeschossen auf
dieser trage
liegt und verletzt wurde wir können
einmal reinschauen in diese szenen und
reinhören also er konnte in dieser
situation mit euch mit den kollegen dort
sprechen ich sie gerade die bilder
liegen uns in der minute noch nicht vor
das sind bilder die gerade reingekommen
sind von euch paul kannst du das
irgendwie einschätzen du musst ja auch
jetzt immer wieder umdrehen von wo kommt
überhaupt der beschuss könnt ihr das
einschätzen
der kollege dass ihre bilder die uns
gerade geschickt habe er mit uns
sprechen kann das ist die einzig gute
nachricht in diesen minuten könnt ihr
irgendwie einschätzen von wo das feuer
kommt
wir sind jetzt hier an einer stelle
wieder ungefähr mit der internen teil
weil sozusagen dort an diesem check
point oder dieser brücke überhaupt kein
handynetz ist und auch keine möglichkeit
ist daten zu übertragen deswegen stehen
wir jetzt hier an diesem ort aber
offenbar hat es weitere verletzte
möglicherweise auch tote dort gegeben
das müssen wir jetzt recherchieren was
genau dort passiert ist wir wissen dass
der beschuss zwischen beiden sozusagen
seiten hin und her gehen wir müssen ja
einmal auch die seiten wieder
also um das noch einmal für unsere
zuschauer kurz einzuordnen pauli
befindet euch gerade an der stadtgrenze
von kiews sein raus nach oben geht seit
vor wenigen minuten eben rein nach
libyen in diese stadt die unter so
heftigen beschuss steht seit wochen
mittlerweile muss man sagen seit mehr
als einer woche und dort eben aktuell
auch beschossen worden ein kollege von
dir von uns ein us journalist der dort
mit seiner fotokamera unterwegs war den
wir gerade dort gesehen haben wie auf
einer trage getragen wurde von auf
weiteren kollegen von euch der dort in
einen krankenwagen verladen wurde der
ansprechbar war der uns gerade sagte ja
es ging natürlich schlecht aber den wir
wenigstens sprechen hören konnten es
muss wahnsinnig gefährlich seien dort
wer schießt dort auf wen auf der straße
kommt das aus der luft kommt das von
scharfschützen könnt ihr das einschätzen
offenbar hat es in scharf bitten die
geben sowohl heute als auch gestern von
russischer seite das ist das was die
ukraine uns berichten das ist schwer
sozusagen einzuordnen in dem moment aber
ständig ist es offenbar so das ist
weitere verletzte und möglicherweise
tote gab bei diesem körper
und wir jetzt recherchieren müssen was
dort genau passiert ist tatsache ist
dass wir auch von weitem neben
scharfschützen immer wieder
artillerie feuer gehört haben ebenfalls
in also die kämpfe dort die kämpfe in
der
die gehen unverändert weiter und das
spielt sich dort ab in diesen korridoren
die putin als humanitär bezeichnet paul
es spielt sich in der stadt ab und kann
noch weiter geht da dem moment wo dieser
journalist heraus getan wurde definitiv
waren auch zwei zivilisten dort wie
versucht haben aus der stadt aus diesem
vor ort raus zu gehen
dann cup monsheimer für diese ja
dramatischen einblicke in die stadt ehrt
ihn vor die tore der hauptstadt kiew
danke